- I hear I owe your friend.
This is a funny story.
Your friend's name is Braeden, right?
That I owe an apology?
- [Lukas Gage] Yes. Yeah.
Braeden Lemasters. He's an actor.
He is in the band The Wallows.
I ditched...I think it might have been
his 21st birthday party
to go to your concert.
- [Kelly Clarkson] This
is a horrible story!
- I know, I know.
It was... I invited a bunch of friends
that had never met him,
and I have these texts
from I think 2019 saying,
"I'm so sorry, I have to bail on you.
It's Kelly Clarkson."
(audience laughs)
- [Lukas Gage] "Babe,
it's Kelly Clarkson."
- [Kelly Clarkson] He's
going to be truly confused
if we show up without you.
- [Lukas Gage] Some people wait a lifetime
for a moment like this.
(audience laughs)
- I love that you invited
people to your friend's party
that he doesn't know, and
then you were like, deuces.
- [Lukas Gage] I mean, listen.
- [Kelly Clarkson]
That's incredibly funny.
- [Lukas Gage] Yeah, I did it for you.
- [Kelly Clarkson] Still friends?
- Still friends.
- Still friends! Yeah.
- I love him. Yeah.
I want to give a public
apology to Braeden Lemasters.
- I am sorry as well.
- From Kelly Clarkson
and myself. I'm sorry.
- How dare I plan a tour on that day?
- Damn you. Damn you.
- That's just hilarious.
I heard that story. I
was like, is that real?
- [Lukas Gage] Oh, it's real.
- My friends would never
let me live that down.